Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to take a look at the Lumen equation.
We'll look at key workflows, limitations, and quality control.
So let's get started.
So Lumen fully supports ICVFX currently.
There can be some noise that occurs, so just be aware of it in your materials.
You can do some adjusting as well as controlling some of the quality there, but the noise may
still persist in particular areas.
So just keep in mind that Lumen is getting better and stronger with each new version.
It's good for Final Pixel and ICVFX, so feel free to play with those and experiment with
them.
It is quick and easy to use and updates on the fly.
It does not currently support caustics, that is what Path Tracer is for.
So make sure if you do need it, you can fake a few things with decals, which we've talked
about in previous material classes, but for the most part, if you want that actual mathematical
accuracy, you'll have to go into Path Tracer to do so.
Again, like I said, it updates on the fly and Lumen is evolving.
It's getting better, faster, stronger with each new version.
Now Lumen uses software ray tracing.
So some limitations can come with this, so keep this in mind.
So software ray tracing requires that levels be composed of modular geometry.
So you need to make things pretty much like Legos.
You need to build a wall, you need to build floors, and you need to make sure that they
have some sort of thickness to them.
If they don't have any thickness to them, you can run into problems.
The distance fields cannot represent extremely thin features or one-sided meshes seen from
behind.
So you make sure that you strategically position your meshes accordingly when that occurs.
So keep that in mind because you can hit some light leaking if you're not careful.
So something to keep in mind there when working with Lumen.
So you can extrude them ahead of time in a DCC, then bring them in, or you can do them
also in Unreal where you extrude them using the modeling tools.
Just be aware that some UV navigation and editing will be needed at that point.
So this has improved avoiding the light leaking in Unreal 5.3, and it's getting better stronger
faster.
But sometimes you just can't avoid the open geometry, such as scans, large mega scans,
scanning that has been done, something that you and your company have scanned.
There may be some open-ended areas, but try to seal this up if you can.
And it just makes things a little bit easier for the mesh distance fields and Lumen to be
calculated correctly so we can prevent some of that light leaking that may be happening.
So mesh distance field resolution is assigned based on the imported scale of the static mesh.
This is something you have to be careful with.
And I've been guilty of this when I first was introduced to Lumen, where you bring in
a small item and you're like, hmm, I need that thing to be twice, three times, four times
bigger than its actual size.
And it mainly happens when you have a dramatic, like two times and maybe not so much, but
something that you need to, that's really small and you make it a lot bigger.
Once you've already imported into the scene, you can run into some weird build errors with
your mesh distance field.
So just keep that in mind.
The resolution on that's going to be a little bit odd.
So you make sure you do those ahead of time before you bring them in and decide to change
their original size that came in.
So Lumen provides two methods of ray tracing in the scene, software ray tracing and hardware
ray tracing.
So this can be a little bit confusing for the people.
So what's happening here is that ray tracing is helping elite, particularly with the software
ray tracing.
It uses mesh distance fields to operate on the widest range of the hardware and performs
and platforms, but is limited to the types of geometry materials workflows it can effectively
use.
So there are some limitations there and that's where the hardware ray tracing leaning on
that is going to be very supportive.
It supports a larger range of geometry types for higher quality by tracing against the
triangles and to evaluate lighting.
This is where you can see the Nanite feature comes into play and helps greatly with this
process.
So we got virtual shadow maps and Nanite and Lumen.
I call them the three musketeers and they all help you to have a nice and beautiful
scene with the highest visual fidelity possible with the best performance.
So to evaluate the lighting, this is actually pretty helpful in here where ray tracing is
concerned and allows you to actually get some really great stuff instead of a lower quality.
Now the surface catch is an option where you can do a higher type of catch on your output
for your objects.
We'll talk about that in the quality control settings here.
It requires supported video cards and systems to operate those.
You got to make sure you have a good system under the hood that allows you to have some
really great GPU processes to be able to lean on when you're using Lumen.
So again, software ray tracing is the only performant option in scenes with many overlapping
instances.
It does help while hardware ray tracing is the only way to achieve high quality mirror
reflections on a surface.
So both give you a bit of the best of the world in Lumen and allow you to have some
good performance going on and quality visuals.
But remember, there may be some noise that still persists and you'll have to do some
editing in there if that occurs.
So Lumen is not compatible with forward shading, but why would you even try this?
Because it does work great out of the box.
You can also use forward shading on that topic.
Was used quite often for VR, but now you can use Lumen for VR, which is pretty fantastic.
So transparent materials aren't ignored by distance fields and mass materials are treated
as opaque.
So just be aware of that.
There's a cafe scene that I show in one of my cinematic lighting courses and you can
definitely see that effect where there's a blurred shader, spiral blurred shader in
a node in the material.
And you can see that there's a bit of noise coming in and it doesn't quite know how to
handle that because it's only on part of the material here and addressed and used on a
particular area of the object, like a texture, like a mask.
So it's mass materials can cause significant overshadowing on foliage too.
So be aware of that too, where large areas of leaves are masked out.
So just be aware and test it out visually.
If you're getting noise, if it doesn't quite look quite right, go in there and do some
editing after the fact.
Distance fields are built off of the properties of the material assigned to the static mass
asset rather than the override component.
So just be aware of this, overriding with a material that has a different blend mode
or that has two-sided property enabled will cause a mismatch between the triangle representation
and the mesh's distance field representation.
So just be aware of this.
That blend mode and two-sided might give you a little bit of issue.
I haven't come across a lot of problems with the two-sided mode being on, on an object.
But then again, you always have to be very deterministic when looking at your foliage
in small areas.
Where there can be an issue though is where you have a bright cloud and you have a foliage
object in front of it and that cloud is giving off a little bit of say, emissive and it has
glowing properties.
What happens is that's when you're going to see this two-sided foliage blended mode and
masked issues occur, there may be some flickering with that foliage that's in front of that particular
object.
So what do you have to do at that point is be very strategic moving things around.
We go over that in world building for virtual production, but I wanted to make mention of
that.
So keep that in mind.
So let's go and take a look at some of the quality settings in here in Unreal.
Again, as you increase these numbers, your GPU, it can be expensive for your GPU.
So you try to start low and then go high.
Now they can, we do go over this in our foundational lighting courses, but I want to walk you through
this before we get on to the next topic.
So let's go and jump into Unreal for a bit.
So in Unreal, in our scene, let's go ahead and get our post-process volume.
In my post-process volume here, I'm going to scroll down a bit here, close a few things
we don't need open.
We'll see that we're in Lumen and we have Lumen global illumination.
We do want to make sure a few things are turned off, which we'll talk about later, to make
sure that we have the best possible performance here.
Now if I increase my light, you'll notice there isn't a whole lot of light bouncing around
in this area here, but if I increase my light, you will see actually your GI get a little
bit stronger, but you have to take an account how bright you want your scene to be.
Now that's when you would bring in something such as a simple light such as a rec light,
so you want to maybe fake some bouncing going on.
So I can simply just bring this in here, move it up out of the way, increase its size a
bit if I wanted to.
So with its size increased, I can now fake that bouncing that is going on by increasing
also the amount of light I have and maybe even change it to be a little more yellow.
So we're faking that sand, giving me some feedback.
So that's one way you can cheat if you need to, if you don't want to increase your overall
lighting, just a quick pro tip there and no one is the wiser.
So let's go ahead and delete that for a second here.
And let's go ahead and take a look at that post process volume.
So in this post process volume, you'll see that our global illumination is Lumen.
So we have our scene Lumen scene lighting quality set up to two.
Now if you want to, you can say, hey man, I'm going to go maybe three, you can do that.
Two works pretty well, but you can go a bit higher.
This overall quality here, you'll see scales Lumen scenes quality, but larger scales cause
Lumen scene to be calculated with a higher fidelity, which can be a visible in reflections
but increased if you cost.
So you're going to see some better reflections as you increase this number, but it's going
to cost your GPU.
Now we definitely want to increase our Lumen scene detail.
So let's go and increase that here.
We're going to keep that at four.
And again, this one sure smaller objects are represented, so, but again, it does cost some
GPU memory.
We have Lumen scene view distance so we can increase the influence of our Lumen accuracy
in our whole environment between that out.
We definitely want to increase our final gather quality.
This is going to remove some noise that's in our scene.
And we also have max trace distance.
Again, I leave that at default, but you can go ahead and it will increase the area that
you're tracing against for your scene.
The values too small will cause lighting to leak into large caves.
So yeah, we got a cave here and we don't want that.
So we want to keep this at the default and we can go maybe a little bit higher if we
needed.
So and we also have seen catcher catch our resolution scale here.
So again, this is helps with our overall look and feel smaller values save GPU memory
at a cost and quality.
So this is going to give us our Lumen surface resolution control here.
Down below we have the advanced settings we can open up here.
Now this is going to give us a refresh that we need speedily and we want to increase this
if we can.
Now this all depends on your GPU.
There's a cheap type of you know, you can think of it as a saturation boost here, diffuse
boost here if you wanted to, you can increase that if you wanted to in your scene.
Now we don't really need to do that, but we can say I want to do five, you'll see you
get a little brighter.
But this can actually maybe help in some areas when you want to get a little bit more of a
bounce.
Watch the sand here as they go increase decrease that number.
So it's at four right now, but I can go and switch that back to one.
You'll see that get darker.
I could even go as high as 10 if I wanted to.
But again, that just gives you kind of a fake type of setting there and you'll see it if
you're not careful.
It can pulse a little bit.
So just keep that in mind.
I like to keep that just as a default one and that works just fine.
You can even keep that at a zero if you wanted to.
They have no reaction whatsoever.
Well, I forget that zero doesn't really take it does take a one.
My bad for that.
And it will not go.
It refuse.
It resists.
It will not go any lower.
Makes sense.
This tells you that it's always active and available and then you can change it from
there.
So we have skylight leaking here.
Now in ray tracing before used to have to evaluate your skylight and so forth and make
sure that it's working because you would get dark areas.
This allows you to control that type of feature here.
So we have skylight leaking and you'll see Unreal helps you out here.
This allows for your interiors, your indoors not to go fully black and allows you to control
that if you need to.
Mine's a little bit dark.
So if I wanted to, I could increase this like maybe two, but you'll notice it brightens
my sand a little too much.
It doesn't quite give me the bounce.
It's really dark over here on this particular object.
So what I can do is just let's move that back down to its default zero and I can put that
light in there.
That's one reason I brought that up in the beginning and just bounce it in here artificially.
Now also you want to make sure that you're using nanite.
So if I'm not using nanite, I want to find that piece of geometry right click in here
and make sure that nanite is active.
This is going to work a bit better in using our virtual shadow maps.
Again does get a little bit dark in some areas, but you'll notice as I move my light around,
everything's being calculated accurately.
It's just that my light isn't very bright and it isn't very high in the sky.
So if I wanted to, I can increase my light even more and you'll actually see the light
bounce in areas that you want.
This is really up to you as you're working through this, but I'm always using fill lights
as much as possible.
And again, that's why I mentioned that earlier.
We can use a fill light to get our light to bounce around like we need and those darker
areas won't be so persistent.
So if we go back to our post-process volume here, let's go back down.
You'll notice we also have the full light leaking distance.
You can actually control that too distance wise if you need.
So just basically how much of that is going to be influencing our Lumen environment.
Down below we have our Lumen Reflections Quality Control Ray Lighting mode.
Notice mine's set to hit.
We have some water we want to have nicely represented.
So you want to make sure that that set had a good amount.
So let me actually move my light back down again.
So we're not having completely blown out scene.
And if I want to, I can just lower my lighting just a little bit there, move it around and
maybe move it higher into the sky here.
We get like an overcast today in the Caribbean.
So you can actually get some really cool effects here.
Cool.
All right.
So back to my post-process volume again.
It's going down a little bit.
You'll see again we have high quality translucency reflections here, which we need for our water.
Can't talk today.
For sure.
And then we have max reflection bounces.
We have set these to three.
We're kind of far away from the water and we're getting probably a little bit of noise
there.
So I'm not too worried about that so much.
What we can do is just edit that material if we needed to a little bit more and get
things into a better position here.
Now again, noise will persist a little bit in some areas.
And notice we have a glowing environment here for our fog.
And in that we have some thin areas, which are getting a little bit of noise.
So again, if you want to, you can actually reposition or make your clouds a little bit
lighter if you needed to and even dumb down your fog.
Now in this particular case, our fogs, exponential height fog, if we scroll up, let's go back
up here for a second.
Notice we're not using volumetric.
So if I turn on volumetrics and I decided to maybe just tone them down a little bit,
you can get maybe slightly less amounts of that going on.
But you'll notice it does flicker a little bit with the trees and these thin areas.
What I would want to do is go and maybe make my clouds a little bit less persistent with
their positioning and move things around.
And you can do that choosing whatever cloud system that you want to use.
Now you'll see a volumetric cloud.
Notice our material and then we can just go into the material and maybe just play with
some of the parameters in here.
That's it with this one.
In the next video, we're going to take a look at some key points in Lumen and some other
details to get the best inner editing when it comes to using it.
Thanks again.